are you one of five and ten Caucasians
that suffers from an embarrassing and
debilitating genetic affliction can you
not leave the house without hitting or
raping a woman unable to resist the urge
to belittle shaman's sexually harass
your female colleagues at work did you
spend your childhood beating the [ __ ]
out of your friends at barbecues do you
still spend your social gatherings
revealing your spectacular raps and
whipping out your member to compare then
I'm afraid what you have feared is true
you suffer from a horrific disease
maleness don't worry my disgusting hairy
friend there is a cure anti man proven
to reduce your testosterone and
eradicate your masculinity within 30
days or your money back
this is the message that's a growing
number of gender activists and
corporations that wish to adopt a
virtuous facade most recently Gillette
would have us believe but what's the
reality here based on social norms that
have been developed over thousands of
years underpinned by biology and using
empirical evidence I seek to rationalize
masculinity and answer an important
question is being masculine bad for
society a good start would be finding
out what is masculinity anyway it is
entirely distinct from an individual's
biological sex
sure masculine traits stem from a person
sex
what if we're getting technical then
masculinity itself is a social construct
that describes a set of traits innately
present in most men the same traits
however can often be found in women not
always undef' into lesser extremes the
traits of masculinity can also differ
slightly between world cultures but the
core traits that define a muscular man
are universally consistent what are
these traits stoicism resilience
strength courage independence and
assertiveness
now before we all judge men for being
too assertive occasionally resorting to
violence or too
stoic for not displaying emotion it's
important to understand where these
traits actually come from the traits
themselves are not social constructs men
don't become masculine just because we
tell them that crying is for girls and
man up masculinity in men may be
enhanced or even enforced by certain
cultures by social pressures but make no
mistake masculine traits originate from
our biology constructed over a period of
two hundred thousand years long ago
nature's doctrine of survival of the
fittest decided that the most efficient
way to perpetuate a species for
reproduction and ensure its longevity
was by dividing each species into two
sexes this division is seen across the
entire animal kingdom what can also be
observed in all animal species and
humans are the different roles inherit
within each sex with the exception of
the male pregnancy witnessed in the
Senedd a family of fish the young of all
species are incubated by the female sex
it's therefore makes sense logistically
that females evolved to have behavioral
and physiological traits that are
conducive to the healthy development and
loving nurture of their young empathy
emotional awareness patience and
tenderness obviously it was also vital
what the females never put themselves or
their young in a situation of danger so
evolution naturally put that onus on the
other sex males males developed a
greater aptitude for physical strength
and the natural courage to hunt to
provide food for their tribe and women
men evolved to have aggressiveness
resilience and assertiveness underpinned
by undying competitiveness so they could
compete against rival males and protect
tribe from other scarier tribes you had
larger plenteous sticks sure those
traits were essential pre civilization
but why can't we get rid of them today
through the systematic emasculation of
men are they not redundant in the 21st
century
don't such traits caused nothing but
toxicity and evil throughout our
societies these are the edicts that many
social justice warriors seek to mandate
on modern men masculinity is a shifting
social construct its very nature has
mutated over the generations today it is
more socially acceptable than ever
before in the history of humanity for a
man to show emotion and share his
feelings with his friends for a man to
cry for a man to choose another man as a
sexual partner and marry him all of
these are truly amazing and undeniably
positive advances towards a better more
harmonic world and none of these things
degrade a man's masculinity but these
are not the traits that authoritarian
leftist activists are trying to suppress
what is under fire is the more assertive
domineering and tough side that is
biologically present in every man to
varying degrees such traits and the
actions which can be associated with
them are too often referred to as toxic
masculinity the issue here is that
so-called toxic behavior is not endemic
to masculine men or even men evil and
malice are present across all
demographic cross-sections of society
there's no denying that men commit crime
and nobody would claim that either sex
is perfect
but before shunning masculinity it's
imperative that we understand how
dangerous this can be for one simple
reason
masculinity does far more good than bad
for everyone
both men and women and not just a little
bit more good for every bad deed that a
man commits in the world I would propose
that well over a thousand good deeds are
carried out by over masculine men every
day only a fool would argue that men
never do but in 2014 seventy-three
percent of those arrested in the US were
male but to live in a society where the
majority of good men are publicly shamed
for the crimes of the minority of bad
men is damaging to the mental health and
sense of purpose of men the world over
especially when this underlying and
natural biological traits of the male
species are being labeled as the cause
of all these evils it also pulls all the
attention away from the many beautiful
things that most masculine men achieve
every single day which vastly outnumber
the horrendous things a much smaller
portion of masculine men do do not
forget that masculinity was born from a
natural desire for men to provide for
and protect their family when a man
takes his daughter to school gives her a
kiss and wishes her a good day that is
masculinity doing good when a man works
10 hours a day to feed clothe and
shelter his family that is masculinity
doing good when a firefighter rescued a
child from a burning building that is
masculinity doing good when a policeman
arrests a perpetrator of domestic abuse
rape or murder
that is masculinity doing good when a
young man shields his sweetheart with
his jacket when it rains that his
masculinity doing good when a surgeon
saves a person's life through open-heart
surgery that's his masculinity doing
good
when Alexander Fleming invented
penicillin saving millions of lives that
was masculinity doing good and when
millions of brave men gave their life
to prevent fascism and tyranny from
engulfing our world in 1914 and 1939
that was masculinity doing good the
truth is trying to control a tiny
minority of bad men by quashing
masculinity in all men is an exercise in
futility and idiocy bad men will not
stop being bad because they become less
masculine they will only become more
frustrated and frustrated people are
more likely to commit injustice than
content people the result will be fewer
good masculine men to stop the bad man
and bad women from being bad masculinity
and femininity are the two pillars that
underpin a cohesive progressive and
productive society that is beneficial to
all shorten or remove either one of
those pillars and society as we know the
society that we built over thousands of
years and the society that we've
protected against tyranny and evil will
come crashing down beneath our very feet
yet how does modern society thank these
everyday incredible men they are widely
vilified on social media in the press in
schools and in popular culture and now
even in advertisements the historic
bastion of greedy capitalism this has
resulted in men committing suicide at
three times the rate of women and these
men who help build and improve our
society every day fate over challenges
at an alarming gray she Oh men are twice
as likely to be the victim of a violent
assault or robbery free put five times
more likely to be murdered 96% of
workplace fatalities happen to men men
are 5.6 times as likely as women to be
incarcerated 86 percent of the homeless
population is male boys have been
lagging behind girls in educational
achievements since 1991 and the gap is
widening every year this last point
indicates a far more concerning [ __ ]
that's the increasing shaming of
masculinity in our schools is causing a
crisis in the development of young men
competitive games that are deemed too
aggressive such as British Bulldog or
tag and dodgeball have been long since
banned in many school playgrounds in the
West a few schools in Britain are even
considering banning the sport of rugby a
fundamental part of masculine
development in young boys since 1823
whilst these games and sports can on
rare occasions cause injuries and
perhaps we should find ways to make them
safer for children they do play a vital
role in developing character and a
strong competitive attitude in young
boys that will enable them to later in
life compete in the workplace and
ultimately protect their family in fact
competitiveness which is predominantly a
masculine trait has been mostly
eradicated from our schools in the West
during sports day and other events
everyone is given a participation award
there is no winner or loser
I failed miserably at sports I finished
last on sports day and I wasn't given a
trophy for taking part I got nothing
and you know what it taught me the next
time I need to try harder that I would
never amount to anything unless I put
the effort in and practice my socks off
not just in sport but in every aspect of
life that was one of the most important
lessons I have ever learned in the same
way that over sanitization during youth
leads to a weak immune system
mollycoddling children is not how strong
societies are built doing so is in
reality a threat to building a strong
Society for the next generation but
nowhere is misandry more rife than in
Swedish schools several preschools and
primary schools in Sweden have gone to
extensive efforts to remove the words
boy and girl from the children's
vocabulary
preferring the gender-neutral pronoun
hen illegal addendum in 1998 mandated
all skills in Sweden to actively work
against gender stereotypes this all
sounds very utopian in theory but in
practice it is nothing short of
brainwashing and it leads to a difficult
and confusing progression into TEENhood
and adulthood for these poor children
they are being taught to ignore basic
science go against the natural
biological pull of their very own bodies
this will only achieve to create a
generation of frustrated passive men
without being free to indulge in their
masculinity in the playground and at
home then these boys will grow into men
who are unable to compete in the
workplace and in personal matters unable
to defend themselves and their families
if evidence of this brainwashing were
needed then I endeavor you to look no
further than seafarers preschool in
Sweden where boys and girls as young as
one are actually segregated so their
natural gender roles can be
systematically indoctrinated out of them
boys are made to play with toy kitchens
and give each other massages girls are
forced to practice shouting no a so
called gender specialist is employed by
the preschool to pick upon and coerce
boys who refuse to partake in feminine
activities such as dance boys are
encouraged to wear dresses and the
teachers celebrated when one particular
girl who used to be very girly according
to her mother was reared by the
preschool to become more boisterous and
her parents noted that she had become
more cheeky and defiant at home
shockingly it was observed that when the
children were no longer forced to play
with toys
typically favored by the opposite gender
that the boys were verted to playing
with cars and the girls dolls the boys
shouted and hit more boys will be boys
the preschool says the
is not okay well golly it's almost as if
their biology compels them to adhere to
their natural gender roles and that
forcibly preventing them from embracing
this is actually child abuse
just a thought an inability to protect
his family is not the only issue that an
emasculating man will face in adulthood
what is just as crucial is a man's
ability to lead and inspire his family
particularly his children when a
masculine presence is stripped away from
an otherwise nuclear family unit the
consequences can often be disastrous
don't get me wrong there is no rule that
children can't thrive in a non nuclear
family different family setups can
absolutely nurture incredible children
but looking solely at fatherlessness
statistics show a clear trend children
who grow up without a father figure are
twice as likely to drop out of school
twice as likely to become obese and four
times as likely to succumb to poverty
they are also more likely to commit
crime go to prison abuse alcohol or
drugs and fatherless girls are seven
times as likely to fall pregnant as a
team after all this rhetoric there's an
important distinction that must be made
I myself and I sincerely hope that other
men out there have no desire to strip
men of their right to choose how they
want to develop through life if men want
to go against their natural masculinity
or even seek to abolish it then we
should all work to protect their rights
to do so and me I say more power to you
but it's so very important that men have
the right to choose just like freedom of
speech it's essential that as a society
we work to protect a man or a woman's
right to live how they want to live be
who they want to be walk how they want
to talk how they want to and wear
whatever they damn welders
but when it comes to a month right to
fully embrace and assert his masculinity
in a positive way it's labeled as sexist
male priviledge by the media and tribal
activists on the internet and on campus
in doing so a man's right to choose to
embrace his masculinity is being eroded
more and more so every year that's why
it's vital that when companies such as
Gillette seek to tar all men with the
same discriminatory brush and suppress
our right to embrace our biology that we
fight to retain our rights to be whoever
the hell we want to be masculinity
should be empowered not shame done
belittled men everywhere must continue
to show the world that overall
masculinity is a force for good not evil
never be ashamed of your masculinity my
hairy friends because it built the road
beneath your feet thank you for watching